hey it's Mike breeder here with on-call
compliance Solutions and I'm back with
another compliance tip of the week this
week we're talking about cmmc control
sc.l2-3.13.3 separate user functionality
from system management functionality
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance
stuff or just the meaning of life on top
of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it so
this control is sort of a basic best
practice let's use the it admin example
in case you're not familiar with this it
admin should not be using a full admin
account at all times bad they should
only be using that admin account when
they are performing administrative
functions the reason is because it makes
it so much easier to detect attacks
where someone may have compromised
credentials and gotten in under an admin
account this is really where your
steamer security information and event
management system is a bigger helper in
identifying those odd logins at 3am by
well you while you were sleeping what's
up with that a huge indicator of attack
if you are mostly using a regular
account then generally speaking it is
much harder to have the admin account
hacked and attacked because that's not
what you're in 90 of the time let's
learn more about about this by reviewing
the assessment points so three points
one determine if user functionality is
identified uh again if we're gonna say
this is implemented we would say user
functionality is identified via active
directory organizational units and user
account levels maybe even access control
is lots and lots of different things
that we could use here next assessment
plan is determine if system management
functionality is identified it's
implemented system management
functionality is identified via access
to system management tools by authorized
privileged users okay one more thing uh
third assessment Point determine if user
functionality is separated from your
system management functionality again we
would say this is implemented and the
evidence is in active directory there's
ous there's security groups again it's
all very well easy to determine there
now if you are struggling or banging
your head against the wall trying to
figure all of this dfar's nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff uh well the good
news is is that we can help we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company so if
you've had this stuff laid in your lap
like a seagull on a sunny day that's
what we're here for baby we can help you
eliminate gaps great areas and get this
solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you uh if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below to get help with
compliance right now love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better Hulk smash that
subscribe button to show us some love
and get the latest compliance content as
soon as our compliance starts roll it
out until the next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and hit us in the comments below to let
us know what you'd like to know more
about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
foreign
[Music]